I think first we got to discuss just how
long he's been playing professional
basketball I think it's been since like
14 15 years old so he's used to seeing
so many different defenses so many
different uh you know different roles
that he's played I'm sure overseas and
now that he's in the NBA I mean you just
see him he plays at an incredible pace
uh he makes great decisions most offense
goes through him and he takes his time a
lot and he gets to the free throw line
so he maximizes on all the rules of the
game of basketball and uh uses his
advantage and all the rest of the guys
around him play the role really well so
they're they're a good team and they're
only getting better uh and again I'm
glad we got to see
a team like this that you know down the
line
um the continuity that they have in the
trust because they've been through
certain battles you can see it and they
don't panic
um that's just good to see traits of a
great team so